la découverte est stupéfiante c'est
après avoir circonscrit l'incendié
déblayer le terrain que les pompiers
sont tombés sur le corps calciné d'un
homme son âge et à définissable les
selon les voisins ils n'auraient pas
péri dans les flammes
des coups de feu auraient été entendus
avant l' incendie une information
transmise au conditionnel l' enquête
judiciaire démarre à peine
quand je suis arrivé
les policiers m'ont appris qu'il y avait
un corps calciné dans la maison mais ils
ne savent pas qu'il ya une enquête est
ouverte
la police scientifique est là ils sont
en train de faire les relevés tous pour
ce qui s'est passé ou également il était
4 heures quand les pompiers sont arrivés
à pau viard ce matin on a frôlé la
catastrophe distille dans un périmètre
aussi étriqué le feu risquait de se
propager rapidement des riverains les
plus proches ont dû être évacuées mais
la difficulté c'est la meilleure c'est
là où sont situés les maisonnettes sont
à l'intérieur deux pâtés de maisons
c'est pour ça qu'ils avaient ce risque
de propagation à d'autres maisons mais
ça a pu être maîtrisé et autrement bon
pas de difficulté particulière n'est que
la maison en bois un maisonnettes en
bois deux maisonnettes en bois en fait
on est il très vite prise par les
flammes est complètement
en embrasser donc en boule et
complètement un quartier sensible
réputé pour ses bâtisses abandonnées
souvent squatté accident ou acte
criminel seules enquêtes pourra
déterminer les causes de cet incendie et
de ce décès qui semble pour l'heure
suspect